man these rappers like yeah they throw
out these little rings and chains or
whatever the cases and people love it
but people really getting the money is
like you know they're getting like a
boatload man like these Executives you
know I think about scooter bro and I
always tell people I'm like I try to get
kids out I try to give kids the the
knowledge I'm like if if really you want
the money don't be the rapper if you
just want to be the guy who's on stage
getting the Applause be the rapper
Scooter Braun bought Taylor Swift's
Masters damn right yeah like and he was
Justin Bieber's manager getting 20 from
that doing a bunch of other smart [ __ ]
getting enough equity bought that [ __ ]
Taylor started crying for years you want
to know something else about that that
nobody talks about well she said no to
the deal originally oh wow to which you
buying her own [ __ ] oh really she was
like nah it's too expensive oh but she
went back trying to do it though right
no no that then she was upset when
scooter but what's the timeline so she
goes to buy it she can't be she doesn't
want to she said that it's too expensive
the deal whatever then scooter buys it
then she makes this big [ __ ] deal
about a man owning a woman's heart and
yeah she did what they spelled it yeah
and I always say there's a few artists
that know they're in that room that they
could do it we have three Kanye
Dave Chappelle and Taylor Swift and
Taylor Swift is doing it right now
because she does there's some beautiful
finesse that's why she said she knows
how to explain this this is actually
she's when she's re-recording all the
songs not only that so she re-recorded
all these songs that she now owns the
masters of that because she didn't buy
which is by the way a great discount
right
um and also it kind of looks I think I
see this article recently that scooter
bro was like he he his biggest regret
with buying it because eventually if the
artist is going to re-record it and they
have that much cachet and clout yeah to
continue like people bought the other
album just as much yeah you didn't
really win right but um with this new
album she's like bringing back the
experience that hasn't existed in music
like we always compare music and movies
the mute the movie like industry
actually survives the
um piracy like they were like yo well
we're just gonna enrich the experience
of going and yeah and people aren't just
gonna keep downloading movies like
illegally and watching at home they're
still gonna we're gonna survive
reclining seats and all that yeah yeah
what the music industry did they were
like well
we can't battle this [ __ ] let's just go
to streaming that was a coping method
right but in reality
if you think about how much streams you
have to get yeah and how money is
getting broken up and just like
distributed across like hundreds of
thousands of artists you're not really
getting the most out of fan base and
Taylor Swift is like the last one who
says yo I'm recording a new album
but I'm putting four songs on the vinyl
version and also as a collector's
ammunition also there's four vinyls and
if you're really a fan you're gonna have
the red blue pink and yellow version and
only the biggest fans you're gonna have
all four yeah and now you got to go find
all four and also let me give you
another incentive if you want to get
access to my tour that's happened in
2023 the only way to unlock those ticket
sales is buying the vinyl fire
out she sold
1.1 million
CDs vinyls iron sets and just digital
albums I mean I I think when you look at
what everyone else is doing in the music
game it's just that there's reliable
streams which is great but you know like
you put your special for sale for for a
while right and I think the perfect mix
is you want people to buy your product
but you also want to Avail to be
streamed exactly right but if they only
stream it it doesn't really establish a
value for you yes if they if you could
show some sales like oh people will
spend these things a lot of money yeah
it's worth a lot 100 you know exactly
how much they're worth so when you go to
a streaming company they have to match
that bare minimum and by the way you
know the amount of cashier she's
wielding she literally told
streaming used to pay out at a very
small rate because there was an
Antiquated contract so the streamer just
got in yeah and she made us think about
it she was writing letters and it's the
only that's what I'm saying she has like
that Kanye Dave Chappelle influence
where the companies were responding to
her letters like Spotify and apple were
like hey it's not our fault it's your
labels yeah and they were all pointing
the fingers but it got solved where the
money got increased a little bit but
it's all because of Taylor Swift she's
just a [ __ ] you know I mean she's a
Visionary in the game yeah or not and
she just got an unbelievable fan base
yeah he really rides with her and
appreciates her and I think rappers just
don't have that they're just too scared
to even try to do it yeah I talked to a
couple rappers I'm like so why aren't
y'all doing this they're like well
tell us to miss her album six months
before
press up that many vitals they're like
yo if Drake Drake submits his album six
weeks before that shit's leaked so and
and it and Drake's album being leaked
affects him way more than Taylor's facts
so if Taylor's album gets leaked three
months before it drops she's still
getting the same sales because those
fans have been conditioned to the
experience and they feel is way more
than the music wow you're just trying to
listen to Drake to hear the hot song for
the moment that you can go to bump it in
the club yeah completely different ball
game yeah yeah